avec laurent wauquiez avec virginie
calmels ce avec damien abad
nous voulons refonder la droite
française et revenir aux responsabilités
en 2022
et pour ce faire nous assumons
totalement de regarder ce qui a marché
chez nous et ce qui n'a pas marché chez
nous notre position vis à vis du front
national à d'une clarté absolue vous la
connaissez il n'y a pas et il n'y aura
pas d'accord avec le front national pour
un certain nombre de raisons nous avons
tiré mariani mais il est un membre des
républicains et ninon et qui hier a
après un rapprochement à une alliance
avec le front national
thierry mariani ne fait pas partie de
l'équipe dirigeante on n'a jamais
interdit au sein des républicains à qui
que ce soit d'avoir sa propre opinion à
moi de le dire
ils viennent de divers mais tout le
monde a le droit de tout dire
heureusement compris de dire tout ce
qu'on veut dans cette phrase il ya
beaucoup de gens chez nous qui ont dit
c'était l'été dernier il faut une
alliance avec emmanuel macron bon il ya
ceux qui l'ont dit pas tout à fait ce
qu'ils ont pu
c'est pas tout à fait même chose mais
c'est la raison pour laquelle nos mais
notre position est très près on peut
faire une ligue 1 et dire il faut
s'allier au front national en mai c'est
un non sujet pourquoi nous sommes 300
mille adhérents
nous sommes le premier parti de france
nous avons 100 députés nous avons la
majorité au sénat je veux bien qu'on
analyse les propos de telle ou telle
quelle est la ligne officielle claire et
définitive de laurent wauquiez et des
républicains pas d'accord avec le front
national pour autant nous revendiquons
n'ont pas le droit mais le devoir de
nous adresser à tous les électeurs parce
que si nous voulons redevenir
majoritaire nous revendiquons ce devoir
de nous adresser aux électeurs de jean
luc mélenchon de monsieur macron de 2017
et de madame le pen bien ensemble